welcome back to las vegas now millions
of people live
every day with severe pain it doesn't
matter if you start hurting today or if
you're dealing with an injury from 30
years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method
of chiropractic care can help
[Music]
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
but they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife fay
oh it's been probably now eight months
ago she started developing
uh tiredness fatigue uh she had
headaches she had nausea
started getting some adjustments and
probably after about three four weeks
she started feeling a little bit better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
tanuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation um and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients uh
young children
um people who've been in bad car
accidents bad falls maybe we've even had
surgery before up to 80 90 year old men
and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two-day workup day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking
every range of motion of their spine
orthopedic neurological test posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward how long is it
going to take what's it going to cost
what's my insurance
do or not do because if you're anything
like me you don't want financial
surprises
we're going to get to work and start
getting some relief as soon as possible
my life's changed immensely i'm
pain-free where i used to have shoulder
neck pain
i wasn't able to lift my arms brush my
own hair it's almost like a
relief when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
normally that two-day work up is 180
what we're gonna do for viewers of the
show is give it to the first
twenty callers i have to limit it after
that it goes up to regular price for
only thirty seven dollars
you heard dr devon the first 20 callers
will only pay
37 for both normally it's 180
call 702 566 hope
or 4673 you can also get more
information at drdevin.com